hey guys cam here with another Gamespot
news update for you square reix has
released a brand new trailer for Final
Fantasy 15 giving us a glimpse of the
story but also actual gameplay the 2 and
1 half minute video opens with a quartet
of Heroes all with immaculately sculpted
hair grouped together in a convertible
cruising through wide stretches of land
populated with mystical creatures the
journey these four Heroes embark on
appears to be at the heart of the story
though details on gamepl are still thin
the video suggests Final Fantasy 15
features battles the player in real time
an uncommon decision for a core numbered
game in the series also hinted at is a
day night cycle as well as Co-op heroics
other highlights from the trailer
include dinosaur type things some sort
of short range blink teleport ability
and this colossal guy who looks like a
snapping turtle who's had a runin with
an enlarging Ray you can check out the
trailer in full over on gamespot.com and
for those of you whose appetite has been
thoroughly Ed by this trailer well good
news Square Enix has confirmed that
there will be a Final Fantasy 15 demo
released in March packaged with the
upcoming Final Fantasy type zero are you
excited for Final Fantasy 15 what's your
favorite Final Fantasy do you think
someone should tell Square in it's
exactly what the word final really means
let me know in the comments down below
and for all other gaming happenings come
on back to
GameSpot